اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من جنوب لبنان اهلا
بكم عدد الشهداء يتجاوز
262 في حين تجاوز عدد الجرحى
64000 وبعد تحكي محكمه العدل الدوليه
توافر عناصر حدوث اباده محتمله في القطاع
نتنياهو يتعهد بمواصله الحرب وحماس تدعو
للضغط على الاحتلال لتنفيذ القرار اربع
دول غربيه بينها الولايات المتحده تعلق
تمويلها للاونروا بعد اتهام اسرائيل
لموظفين بمساعده حماس الحركه ادانت تحريض
الاحتلال ودعت الامم المتحده الى عدم
الرضوخ للتهديدات في حين اكدت النروج
استمرار دعم الفلسطينيين من خلال الاونور
اشتباكات بين المقاومه وجيش الاحتلال شمال
غرب مدينه غزه سرايا القدس تقصف سديروت
ونير عام بالصواريخ وكتائب القسام تبث
شريطا لثلاث مجندات اسرائيليات اسيرات
يطالبن حكومه نتنياهو بوقف الحرب واعادته
لعائلاتهن في الضفه الغربيه استشهاد شاب
فلسطيني برصاص الاحتلال شرق جنين والجيش
الاسرائيلي يشن حمله اقتحامات شملت بيرزيت
شمال رام الله وبيت فوريك شرق نابلس في
حين اعلن نادي الاسير الفلسطيني اعتقال 20
شخصا بالضفه الغربيه بينهم اسرى سابقون
حزب الله يهاجم بصواريخ بركان تجمعا لجنود
الاحتلال في محيط موقع جل العلام ويستهدف
موقع العباد وسكنه دفيف وقاعده خربه ماعر
بينما اعلن الجيش الاسرائيلي سقوط اربعه
صواريخ من جنوب لبنان في بلده شلومي
بالجليل الاعلى الى
اللقاء